Hello world, in this video I'll be
introducing interval notation and talk
about some common sets. This will lay the foundation for the next video on set
builder notation. The beauty of interval
notation is that allows us to officially
described all numbers between two values.
Suppose we want to say that the variable
X is between Zero and 1.
Well, we could do just that we can say
that X is an element of the
interval Zero, 1. Or, which is really saying X
is greater than Zero and X is less than 1.
Likewise, if we wanted to say that X is
greater than or equal to Zero and X is less
than 1 then we have to switch this to a
square bracket. All we're doing is we're
now including the number Zero in the
interval. Also we can include Zero and we
can also include 1 in the interval by using
square brackets on both sides. So it's
greater than or equal and
less than or equal to. And now talk about
some common sets, the first one being the
null set, which is the same thing as the
empty set, which is just there are no
elements contained within the set and
this will come in handy future. The funny
N here is the natural numbers, which is
the set containing elements 1, 2, 3, and then
these thre e dots here called an ellipsis,
which tells us that the pattern
continues. So, N is the set containing
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7 all the way up to infinity. This funny N with a Zero is the natural
numbers, however it includes the value
Zero within the set. So it's 0, 1, 2 in the
ellipsis tells us all the way to
infinity in an integer Zero, 1, 2, 3, 4,
5, 6. And finally, we have all the
integers positive and negative and non
which is Zero, negative 1, negative 2 all the
way down to negative infinity, and Zero, 1, 2,
3, 4, all the way up to infinity.